hello and welcome to this video playing
F and I don't know that come I have
problems dance with this name okay I'm
playing and playing this some recently
posted that I should play for once in a
while so here we go we get a dragon main
line yeah this this ending here the
ending is a bit much it sir yeah it's um
so what simplified position is probably
the right word is a bit better for wives
but I'm not really an expert some good
theme I looked at this one and found it
to be quite unattractive for black but
i'm not sure if I'm doing it right here
I wonder if some be five now as possible
I don't know if it actually helps them
dr. Philip lecture to everyone in five
yeah so going to be six something that I
expect to happen and i don't know i
think i want to keep keep c5 undercover
if i play Queen age for Queen B 693 it's
not a move I want to play I once want to
have a knight to e5 possible it's a lot
easier m to develop the bishop like
Bishop f5 sg4 probably very likely Queen
B 6 a plague there should be three I'm
okay with that okay push it back yes yes
yes yes but I have an 84 here right just
stopping this or I could also offer a
queen trade with 94 then I would be
slightly better after the Queen's are
traded i think so i'm trying trying to
that he does not have that many good
good squares can go back to see seventh
but i don't think this is particularly
attractive
huh oh I didn't miss I miss that I miss
dad takes Knight takes that's a good one
oh wow that was that was good
okay and what happens here can I I have
to do something drastic and something
longer doesn't cut it and peace down
after Queen B 6 bishop is for Queen B 2
also just use this okay and I have to
play this a be 45 just hope for
something working down so takes Knight
f6 check it doesn't work which is just
not look and you have to get a little
fresh chicken out a for the good move I
also love to Calais down you can just
take it 9 f 16 g 7i have nothing King f7
the night hangs and I don't have like
Knight f6 night eh54 drove across the
queen is covering the sixth-ranked yeah
this is this is a draw at least for me
can I win canal win probably not huh yes
okay let's do this and then see if I can
do more than a draw
yeah I was very lucky could just take a
look now if I'm completely missed a full
of course that was a very cute move
check
yeah yeah I have to make the job I mean
it's more than I deserved him check
check wrong and wrong and so yeah this
is I think a normal line this feels
feels all very normal yeah now i have to
play differently 994 is just a blunt
that you change form that was a nice
move really the engine suggest this I do
like my position a lot e I think and
black isn't some trouble here
strategically nine on 65 is very good a
force blocked him unless you allow a
tactic and white has easy ideas H form
or loopy one just plain the center I
think why does better in this position
and he is better in this whole line
which I think yeah makes the dragon a
pretty unattractive opening jeff and i
miss a form yeah here you just hear you
just worse by a mile look t5s actually
still playable and I should have done
that and we do this just to lose total
am and they just have to take and and
that's it yeah and nothing happens now I
cannot show just because the queen is
interpolant what orders I mean I have no
check there is only extremely lucky tall
there ok guys thanks for watching